this is a production of Cornell
University well I'm super jazzed about
today many of my favorite researchers
and favorite farmers are here today so
I'm really looking forward to the the
rest of the day yeah so my name is John
Wallace I just started at Cornell and
I'm gonna be working in specialty crop
systems and when it comes to talking
about use cover crops to suppress weeds
I really feel like I'm just the
messenger so I've really had the
pleasure to work with a host of
researchers in the Northeast for the
last several years who have been
thinking about this and the idea is I'm
going to talk about a lot longer than me
and then an important part of this story
are the farmers who are putting these
ideas into practice and several
gentlemen who have provided engineering
solutions that have allowed us to use
cover crops in new ways and then I also
thought it was important important to
note that when this group of scientists
over here when we write papers we
typically end up citing the work of
Chuck Moeller and John Teasdale who did
a lot of really important early work
looking at cover crop and weed
interactions so I'm working off of the
assumption that since you guys are here
today we're gonna be in general
agreement that cover crops are a
potential tool and the integrated weed
management toolbox or one of the many
little hammers that we can employ to
achieve certain long-term weed
management objectives and so when we
turn when we think about long term
integrated weed management we're
thinking about maintaining low weed seed
banks and annual cropping systems and
also preventing population spikes so
kind of buffering against those years
when we have poor weed control and
really high weed seed rain
and then also what we want to do with an
integrated weed management approach is
to prevent weeds that become adapted to
our system so adapted weed species and
so we also we know a little bit about
the mechanisms the mechanisms by which
cover crops suppress weeds and disrupt
weed life cycles and so whether we're
talking about a living color cover or
surface mulch or residue
we know that the cover crops can affect
what's going on in the weed seed bank by
alternating germination cues so light
quality changes in soil temperatures
soil moisture that trigger weed seed
germination cover crops can also enhance
habitat for seed predators so grain of
Orr's that can also help drive down weed
seed banks and we also have some
evidence that cover crops influence
microbial diversity in the soil and that
diversity can contribute to greater weed
see decay and then above-ground we know
that a living cover through competition
or the surface mulch through physical
interference can kind of preempt
resources away from from weeds and
influence by altering so the moisture
dynamics the nitrogen availability
increasing competition for light and all
those things can contribute to either
mortality of emerged needs or at least
kind of decreasing the amount of seed
rain in annual cropping systems
so the intensity by which cover crops
influence those weed life cycles is
really a function of certain life
history traits of weeds and as well
where you're employing cover crops
within a rotation and so if we're kind
of thinking about business as usual
where we're using cover crops in the
shoulder seasons within an annual crop
rotation we're very likely have pretty
dramatic effects with on winter annual
weeds like mayor's tail that germinate
in the fall or in the spring but we may
kind of have marginal effects on summer
annual weed species so we might prevent
some weed seed germination for early
emerging summer annuals but for summer
annuals that have peak emergence periods
in crop in a summer annual crop cover
crops likely have pretty marginal
effects on weed seed on weed dynamics
and so you know in the two extremes and
when we're in an annual crop rotation
say in a full tillage organic system or
in a continuous no-till conventional
system where and we're relying on either
these these big hammers tillage or
multiple passes of herbicides were very
likely to be still selecting for adapted
wheat species and those systems and
cover crops may have a marginal marginal
effect so what I'd like to talk about
today is opportunities for making cover
crops a bigger hammer in the integrated
weed management toolbox in conservation
tillage systems both organic and
conventional systems by moving cover
crops closer or into summer annual crop
rotations and so the two common things
going on there are the need to move away
from kind of business as usual and
either terminating a cover
with herbicides or tillage early and
delaying termination to allow cover
crops to get big and then relying on a
surface mulch residue for increase weed
suppression so we've been working we
know quite a bit about using this kind
of high residue cover crop mulch system
in organic systems so in the Northeast
there's been probably over a decade of
research looking at this system and what
we would call a cover crop based or
organic rotational no-till system and so
what I want to do is just touch on how
that system works what we've learned and
then if we can take what we've learned
from that system and start to employ
that in more of a conventional
continuous no-till system so to really
make cover crops a bigger tool in the
integrated weed management toolbox so we
employ this system both in a no-till
corn or a no-till soybean phase of the
rotation and I'm just going to use for
example a no-till soybeans system so in
this particular system many are you many
of you are going to be familiar with it
the idea is to grow a big cover crop and
so we really prioritize optimizing
getting that cover crop established in
front of soybeans who are typically
growing cereal rye so we're getting that
cover crop in early at a high seeding
rate with the idea of growing a big
cover and we're terminating cereal rye
at flowering at thisis with a roller
crimper and then we're no-till planting
soybeans directly into that so that
mulch and what's critical is this
trade-off of when we're doing minimal
kind of disturbance at planting in row
we do a better job of suppressing weeds
but we consistently consistently see a
trade-off where sometimes it's harder to
good crop establishment when we're
planting into that big residue and so
we're not always going to get the
biomass that we think we need so
typically in that system we think we
probably need about three tons of dry
matter biomass to get a really good beat
suppressive mulch
when we terminate the cover crop and so
we've been thinking about integrated
weed management approaches and so we've
been integrating the use of a high
residue cultivator in this system and so
the way that that works is there's these
high residue sweeps they're about 20
inches wide and they don't invert the
soil so they kill weeds by actually
severing the roots and so that allows
you to go in later than what we would
typically use in Tyrell cultivation and
make what we what we have found is two
passes about four or five weeks after
planting generally optimizes in row weed
control when we integrate this high
residue cultivator into the system so
here's some data from a long term
organic cropping systems experiment
that's looking at these rotational
no-till approaches at Penn State this is
some data from Rebecca Champaign who's a
master student there and so in this
cropping systems experiment of Penn
State we have we're comparing kind of
full tillage soybean production with
this rotational no.2 approach using the
cover crops and the roller crimper and
so this this data is late-season weed
biomass for three different crop years
and the lead biomass is broken down by
in row weeds and then between row weeds
and so on x-axis you can also see the
number of cultivation passes so for the
full tillage system we're using blind
cultivation or interval cultivation
somewhere between three or six times a
year depending on weather conditions and
then kind of adaptively using
hi residue cultivation in the no-till
system and you can see here what kind of
biomass we were getting it with the
cereal rye cover crop so looking at this
data what have we really learned about
the viability of the no-till approach
one is that if you look across the
rotation we're seeing pretty comparable
levels of weed suppression between the
no-till approach and the full tillage
approach and we also are seeing that
both of these types of systems are
pretty vulnerable to we control failures
and those we control failures happen are
primarily a function of we control
failures in row so in 2016 in the full
tillage right after planting we stayed
wet we couldn't get into blind
cultivation and then when it dried up we
couldn't we couldn't get those weeds out
of the row the story is a little bit
different in the no-till system so in
that system we had a pretty high weed
seed bank inputs in 2016 which was a
challenging year and the in row weeds
are probably due to too much soil
disturbance at planting and then we're
also finding that which i think is
important because a lot of the original
work was really thinking about driving
up
Serio rye biomass to get a better weed
suppressive mulching you see that from
year to year
weed control is not really a function of
how much Sarabhai biomass and and part
of that is the ability to have this
integrated approach where we use high
residue cultivation and what I'm not
showing is the weed species breakdown
and if I did what you would see is both
of these systems are pretty vulnerable
to species becoming adapted so in each
year the proportion of total weeds we
saw giant foxtail become more and more
dominant in these systems and so it's
just another another data point that
suggests that
we need to think about integrated
approaches within season and across
rotations to really manage manage weeds
okay so what are the opportunities for
kind of thinking about using this high
residue surface multi-protein continuous
conventional no-till systems and so
we've we've been thinking about that and
and one of the one of the things that
have made this approach more conceivable
is this small engineering solution so
this this is a integrated roller crimper
it's called a er X his own residue
manager system Don biologic sells it now
it was it was fabricated by a
Pennsylvania no-till farmer and what
this allows you to do is to a roll and
plant in one pass so you can mount these
on on the frame ahead of your no-till
planter so there would be a slicing
residue behind here followed by the
no-till planter units and it also allows
you to be a little more aggressive with
these double disc row cleaners in in row
and so when we're using herbicides in
this system we can be a little more
aggressive to make sure that we're
establishing a good crop and use
herbicides to control weeds in the row
and so we've been trying to think about
how this approach is going to influence
herbicide programs or the use of
herbicides in these systems and so
there's a couple of things going on one
when we're using kind of the roller
crimper approach in a conventional
system we have a lot more flexibility
and when we termination terminate the
cover crop and that's really important
because it's not really just how much
biomass you're getting but we're
consistently challenged by weather
conditions when you can get into the
field and terminate a cover crop and so
being able to use burndown herbicides
allow us a little more flexibility in
managing the cover crop residue and then
we what we would like to think is that
by moving to this kind of
residue mulch approach we have the
opportunities to reduce the amount of
residual herbicides or post herbicides
that we're going to rely on in a
continuous no-till system and that is
really critical given that northeast is
now seeing the introduction of more and
more glyphosate resistant weeds in our
notes whole cropping systems and so
thinking broadly about this we're
thinking that adopting this approach of
these higher residue mall systems and
continuous no-till is potentially
critical enough where we're thinking
about preserving conservation tillage
systems by diversifying our weed
management approach which allows us to
preserve effective herbicides and we do
that by preventing the evolution of
herbicide resistant weeds and if that's
gonna happen we really think that it was
necessary for cover crops and herbicide
programs to be complementary and so when
we're thinking about complementarity
between herbicides and cover crops were
thinking about three things so this is
how we're thinking about if cover crops
are complementary if at the time of a
herbicide application were spraying
fewer weeds because if we're spraying
fewer weeds for removing selection
pressure away from herbicides and that
mortality pressure is coming from the
cover crops and that's a positive thing
it's okay so and then it's also a
complementary if we reducing weed size
at the time of application so extension
weed scientists everywhere always talk
about the finger roll or the soda-can
rule and that killing weeds with
herbicides is a dose is about dose
response and so if leads are smaller one
drop of a herbicide is going to be more
effective when they're smaller at the
same time if we're spraying smaller
weeds and we're spraying through a cover
crop there's the potential for kind of
interference from the cover crop
that may potentially reduce herbicide
efficacy so I'm just gonna show some
data that kind of looks at this
complementarity issue and so this is
this is a mayor's tale example so
mayor's tails are wearing a weed it's
probably the poster child for glyphosate
resistant weeds in the Northeast and so
the selection pressure is occurring at
burndown and so what we would like to
see is to spray fewer mayor's tail
plants at burn down and what this data
shows is across four different years the
the this is a mayor's tail density the
black lines are no cover crop plot the
green lines are where we have a cereal
rye cover crop and you can see that in
three out of four years the potential
for reducing the number of weeds that
were spraying removing selection
pressure away from those herbicides is
potentially greater than ninety percent
so that's that's a really positive
outcome so this is the same data and so
how big were those horse weed plants
when we were using a burned-down
herbicide to kill them and so the top
this is two different ears and the top
is with the no cover the bottom is with
cereal rye and you can see that when we
don't have the cover we're increasing
the probability of violating the
soda-can rule
so we're spraying bare weeds when we
don't have the cover crop there and when
we do the cover crop we've really
constrained weed size and and we're
spraying smaller weeds okay so this is
some data from Jess panchak who is
working on this idea of interference so
the potential for cover crops to
interfere with the efficacy of
herbicides and so this is here this is
herbicide spray coverage at the time of
burndown herbicide application this is
the amount of ground cover that we have
and so you see the control 0 rye and a
rye hairy vetch cover crop
and you can see that as you increase
ground cover with a cover crop the
deposition of the herbicide goes down
and so this is potential negative trade
off associated with with using cover
crops oh yeah so I have pictures so
that's the picture she was using spray
cards to actually measure this so that
that's what looks that's the herbicide
deposition and a no cover crop plot and
in a hairy vetch here at rye cover crop
yeah couple more slides ok all right
so mmm so that's that's kind of winter
annuals where we really have kind of
potential to really drive weed
suppression or increase weed suppression
with cover cropping so what about those
summer annual weeds that have peak
emergence periods in crop particularly
late emerging weeds like pig weed
species and so how much weed suppression
can we get out of that surface mulch
residue so this is this is a data set
from the same set of experiments what
we're looking at pigweed density at the
time of a post emergent application so
about three weeks after planting and
this is a x-axis UFC arrived biomass at
burned down and so we have no cover crop
plots we have CRI plots where we
terminated at the boot stage and then
where we terminated at the heading stage
and you can see that increasing the
amount of biomass prior determination
increases the surface residue and while
compared a horse weed it may be more a
more marginal effect we're still driving
down or we're so increasing weed
suppression and those summer annual
weeds same idea with what are we doing
to weed size so probably not as
demonstrable is kind of the horse weed
data but we're still seeing that when we
have the surface malas to do there we we
have fewer weeds they're getting big at
the time of a post emergent application
so we're probably slightly more probable
to violate the finger rule or the
soda-can rule and the no cover crop
control okay so just to wrap things up I
would like to think from this data that
the question of can we make cover crops
a bigger tool in the toolbox in an
integrated way management approach by
moving to this high residue surface
mulch we see a lot of signs that this
this could be effective but I also
didn't talk about all the potential
agronomic trade-offs I talked about the
weed suppression benefits and so if we
want to move forward and make this
something that is really viable there's
still some challenges and so in organic
system the organic no-till system I
think one of the the critical challenges
is just getting these consistent crop
stands while minimizing in row
disturbance and so that that might be
just a technological fix in conventional
systems we still have all these question
marks so what about this interference
question trade offs are we adding
additional pest pressure other than
weeds yield drags do the shortened
seasons so these are important questions
I talked solely about CRI alone I didn't
talk about mixtures so when we start
thinking about integrating cover crop
mixtures into the end of the question we
maybe will add we have greater weed
suppression but probably increase the
complexity of management and then
finally this approach requires
investments in capital and new equipment
and so is that investment really worth
long term conservation benefits sorry
okay so I hope I have time for a couple
questions or comments
[Applause]
we're using
the no-till approach versus the oh yeah
so totally different cultivation
equipment so in the no-till systems
we're using that high residue sweep so
one one sweep and then in the in the
pool tillage system we would be using
blank cultivation so either a tiny weed
or a rotor Harrow and then just
Interrail cultivation yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu